hello robert how are you
what's going on tom holland
how's things i'm i'm things are good man
we got a foot and a half of snow outside
so as well as they can be i guess nice
where in the world are you
i am in colorado and and trying to find
a way to move to los angeles
nice okay good luck with that yeah man i
appreciate it um
okay so uh one
love the uncharted movie i'm a huge fan
of the uncharted series i actually
started with four and then played one
two and three after um
you did that
yeah
yeah
that's nuts man um
so here's a question i have right
because since
you stepped into the mcu right you've
had roles like devil all the time and
stuff like that you know outside of like
spider-man and so on so with uncharted
since this is like the first theatrical
release after the the spider-man
franchise at least for now is
essentially done um are you gonna stick
with like the whole action-adventure
thing or are you gonna do like a breadth
of different roles that require
different
i guess
talents
i don't know how to describe that
uh
i i'm just always going to try and
challenge myself with new things
you know uh
nathan drake playing this character has
been a huge challenge for me because you
know it sort of fits into the category
of this action-adventure world which
spider-man is very much a part of but
you know i am very proud that i think
this character is a huge departure from
peter parker but you know i do have lots
of other jobs coming up uh that are very
very different you know i'm doing this
sort of courtroom drama um this year uh
which is a tv show for apple i have a
few independent films that i'm working
on and producing at the moment which are
really cool so you know i'm just trying
to diversify
uh
my um
sort of
taste in in work uh but you know at the
heart of it my favorite kind of movies
to make are these big action movies yeah
that's awesome because i'm i'm a huge
fan so i'm you know i have no doubt your
career is just
just getting started i appreciate it
yeah man um so here's my next question
could nathan drake successfully break
into the avengers compound without
getting caught
could he successfully break into the
avengers compound without getting caught
uh
[Music]
yeah i reckon he could i mean he is the
world's greatest treasure hunter and
thief so i'm sure there is a vent
somewhere that he could figure out how
to crawl into
uh but i would wonder what would happen
if he would run into spider-man i i
would be intrigued to see how that would
go
uh well how would it go
i don't know that i'm not the writer i'm
just the actor
that's fair enough um and i guess my
last question uh
in the next uncharted movie because i
have no doubt there'll be a second one
if you could steal anything in the world
what would it be
if nathan drake could steal anything in
the world what would it be god that's a
massive question and i'm not sure i'm
really not sure what it is i think uh
something that i would be really
intrigued to explore would be ancient
egypt i recently as tom holland have
developed a massive intrigue into you
know that part of history i've been
watching all these documentaries on on
disney plus with you know
all about the great pyramids and the
tombs and these tomb raiders and stuff
like that i think there could be a
really really interesting story for nate
and sully uh in and around egypt i also
would love to go there i've never been
there so it would be a nice excuse to
get paid and to go on holiday all at the
same time
yeah man i can't imagine very many
circumstances where people are like
where they don't want to get paid to go
to a place like literally your job tom
holland and mark wahlberg is to go here
do some stuff and get paid to do it and
that's absolutely the area while you're
there yes
living the dream well i appreciate it
man thanks for your time it's always a
pleasure interviewing you so yeah thanks
a lot dude i appreciate it what's going
on sophia okay i'm sorry i was waiting
for them to say something
uh you look fantastic
thank you
yes um okay so the character of chloe
frazier i'm a huge fan of the uncharted
series by the way so when i got the
offer to do the press chunk and i was
like absolutely i love this series um so
chloe frazier is described and i i
paraphrase here um a darker and more
ruthless version
of nathan drake with like little hints
of indiana jones
so my question is
what was it like reading about the
character and then actually playing the
character in the film
um
it was exciting
scary you know because
she is ruthless and
i want to portray that right but
it's hard
yeah i'm not so ruthless you know
personally
really
i don't know i i
i definitely don't chase up
no that's a lie do chase after gold
[Laughter]
i love gold gold things called necklaces
gold rings love it
oh fair enough um so the the whole cast
looked like it meshed
incredibly well right i mean just
watching the movie it looks like that
right like you see actors portraying
roles things like that and there's a
kind of chemistry that like just stands
out
right so uh i guess my question is one
um what were like the best moments to
film in terms of as much of the cast
being together as possible and then two
uh were there any pranks
um were there any pranks yeah there were
some pranks i think
yeah there were pranks just little ones
you know like
false starts or you know if we were
doing like stunts or something and
something fell like
yeah fall starts i i remember there was
like a door scene and
it it was gonna fall and um someone was
standing underneath it tom i believe and
like mark pushed it over
and he did it too soon and like got him
that's funny um
it's not funny when you have to they you
know explain
there wasn't any was like oh we put
nutella all over his trailer and he
thought he had someone came in and
pooped everywhere you know
we didn't do anything like that like
that's fair
i wish we hadn't now that i said it out
loud
should have done that would have been
funny
okay well i appreciate it um yeah this
is a pretty short one you know but uh
but yeah thank you thank you for your
time oh thank you thank you
hi robert nice to meet you oh hey what's
going on
thanks that hair looks amazing
thanks so much
my stylist did it she did it up
it looks phenomenal i absolutely love it
um
what's going on
but nothing much you know hanging
chilling a little bit of ellen
yes what's going on with you
uh
about the same thing yeah just chilling
just hanging out um
okay
so
here's a question that i have where i
kind of have a whole bunch of questions
but um i guess i'll keep it simple for
the first one what was your favorite
scene to shoot the most cliche question
ever
um my favorite scene
was
the ending boat sequence
um
i guess you can you can even call that
several different scenes kind of all put
together but it was a really fun
sequence to try to like map out and put
all together yeah the boat battle
okay so um so your character braddock
right
wow uh
all my lights just turned
yellow
oh wow
that's fun
they're set on a timer so they
automatically do it um but your
character braddock is um is is wholly
new to the uncharted franchise
right never appeared in a video game
before so you got chloe frazier you got
nathan drake you've got solely all that
kind of stuff
so a lot of people know what to expect
for those characters
but they don't know exactly what to
expect from your character
so what can they expect
um they can expect hopefully
um
someone that very that very easily can
slide into in to these games and and
feel like a real part of this world um i
took a lot of inspiration um from nadine
and rafe within the games um to sort of
start to inform braddock and and find
her
um
uh
yeah they can expect somebody who's
ruthless um who's calculating um
and due to
that ruthlessness
and cunning
she's a very scary woman
um that you definitely don't want to
ever step in front of
um
yeah i just hope that i hope that they
accept her into this world yeah
awesome okay my last question here um
coming off of that
from what i've seen on social social
media people are hyped about braddock
and they really are drawing those those
comparisons with nadine right so what's
it like looking at people's reactions to
the character of braddock and seeing
people who were just excited
um it's such a like it's such an honor
because like i was so nervous stepping
into this like because i know that i'm
chartered as a huge fan base and like
that like you know like
who knows if that like i was like oh my
god i hope they don't reject this
character because it's not actually in
the games but
um it's it's very rewarding it's like oh
it really warms my heart and makes me
feel good it's like okay well
hopefully i i make them even proud
further when they get to see it and i
hope they fall in love with her
awesome well i appreciate you giving me
your time uh but i gotta bounce but uh
yeah
thank you so much robert have a
wonderful rest of your evening
mark wahlberg what's up man what's up
bud how are you dude i'm doing good man
i'm a massive fan i love the whole
mustache oh thank you i appreciate it
yeah yeah it looks great uh loved
uncharted right movie was absolutely
phenomenal so i guess like the basic
question everybody starts off with right
like you know uh
what was your motivation for playing
sully and
uncharted oh well i aged out of playing
nathan drake i was uh i was originally
attached to playing eight and then uh
cut to you know 13 years later i was too
old for that part
and i like the idea of playing sully it
was cool you know i'm kind of trying to
age gracefully and you know i embraced
uh playing you know older characters and
here's the guy who is much smarter and
experienced and you know he's also
you know the kind of guy you don't know
which way he's going to go he's
untrustworthy it was just a lot more
room to play as opposed to me trying to
be believable playing you know a young
kid who was naive and you know
uh green so
yeah um well i have to ask this question
because i'm afraid i might not have time
uh i've been a fan for years man like
for years like wasn't the big hit you
and lou diamond phillips oh yeah yeah
pokemon everybody yeah yeah man go way
back so uh what are we going to see you
in a marvel movie that's what i want to
know uh no plans yet i mean you never
know if the right role came around uh
but i'm certainly not looking to uh you
know put on a cape and uh uh spandex
suit just yet i don't have uh i think i
have quite the courage to do that just
yet
okay i really really really want to see
that um oh and then the next thing is
for people out there who aren't really
familiar with uncharted um the whole
relationship between sully and uh and
nathan drake is one of like a mentor
slash father figure you know kind of
thing um so how does that apply in in
this
well yeah i mean it's one of those
things where sully really is basically
just trying to recruit somebody to help
him achieve his objective right he's got
one thing on his mind and that's finding
the goals he doesn't care who he has to
use or how he has to manipulate him to
get to you know to do what he wants and
then he slowly starts to really
feel for for nate and just kind of have
this kind of he starts to bond with him
but there's great chemistry between the
two of us you know you don't know if
sally's going to just kind of use him
like he's used everybody else and then
ultimately you know even though they're
butting heads the whole time they'll
become a team
and it's it's definitely earned in the
film it's not one of those things that
just comes easy you know he's a thorn
and sully side but sully's got to use
him to get you know to get you know to
the goal so
it meant for a really fun and
interesting dynamic between the two of
us yeah i i love that whole dynamic um
so uh i guess what i would ask is like
what comes after this for like you and
uncharted and all that stuff
it really depends i think if audiences
love the movie i mean the response has
been great but if they really love the
movie and we can make one that's better
than the first then i'm certainly open
to it because it was smart how we kind
of introduced these characters into the
uncharted world they still kind of uh
pretty early on in the uncharted journey
so i think you have an opportunity to go
in many different directions so we we
kind of left a little bit of a tag there
at the end uh you know it could be el
dorado and there's lots lots of
different ways to go with it yeah and
that kind of goes into my final question
here um and i asked this for for tom
hall and ask him the same thing if
there's any one thing you could steal in
the second uncharted movie regardless of
where it is in the world what would it
be
oh god that's that's that's a tough one
there's so many so many different
options and uh you know again at me
being me i've got a i've gotta you know
walk that fine line and say i wouldn't
really steal anything if if we did if we
were able to recover something we would
donate it to a museum
that works that works oh well i
appreciate your time man it's always
awesome this is so exciting for me so
yeah thanks a lot dude yeah thanks bud i
appreciate it thank you